see something i'm thinking about is if
these were indeed operable which you're
not saying they are
and if the navy or the u.s government
did indeed believe in them
then they could easily file it under a
secrecy act they didn't have to make it
public so do you feel like you're
suffering why do they make it public and
is part of the reason because it's a
preemptive strike against the
possibility of it being one day
developed by a competitor
i think my opinion uh just look at rose
cole hart's uh book name in plain sight
sometimes the best way to hide something
is in plain sight
what does that mean
i'm remember i'm just a lowly
podcaster
a failed filmmaker so explain what that
means please
it's quite possible that no one knows
exactly
the end effect of all this work
and therefore why why classify it why
and and even if it was
correct and it could lead to all these
breakthroughs sometimes the best way to
hide something is in plain sight
because again
who would
do you see any mainstream physicists
trying to take on the vice effect and
trying to prove its validity absolutely
not they would rather call me a crank
and crackpot and shout and rather than
try to do the experiments and see
whether they work or not
so it's much easier to call it a work of
disinformation
and leave it at that
my biggest fear is that
certain
nefarious elements would pick up on this
work and
find validity within it
and that's why
language was made
specifically in those patent
applications to deter any such nefarious
elements from proceeding
on some of these ideas uh
let's just leave it at that i cannot
substantiate what that means
your viewers are very intelligent so i
know they will pick up on certain things
okay i'm not terribly intelligent so
let's so let me ask you a question and
then you can choose to answer or not the
way that you describe quantum gravity
sir speaks against that volumes
what i'm thinking is see i'm going
through it and i'm trying at least
arduously to take it seriously
and to wrestle with it and go through
the details and i personally didn't see
anything in there that would say to a
country who doesn't have our interests
at hand who knows even if our own
government has our own interests and who
knows but
you understand what i'm referring to i
didn't see anything in there that would
stop them from doing the same
investigation that i'm doing so what
what are you what are you referring to
what do you mean can you talk around it
i left out some of the secret sauce
okay now what do you make once people
say well there has to be disinformation
in it not just incomplete information
disinformation
i did not write these patent
applications and i'm pretty sure the
government did not file them in order to
create
false information
these would
written
to the physics of the effects that i was
following through
that's all
they were not meant to
scare off anybody
they're a new window into new
opportunities and
it's quite possible again these have
such commercial
possibilities
they don't need to be weaponized
if indeed the bias effect
or the schwinger effect or whatever i
want to call it
if indeed this effect is valid
it could lead to new
to a new world
why not
give it that opportunity
that's all
and i really wanted the navy to have
these because if if any of the
contractors if any of the uh
companies that
form the military-industrial complex
if if any of them have or
will come up with these ideas
they would charge navy great amounts of
money
to to make them feasible
if the navy already has them
those prices can be talked down
be alleviated and
that's why i actually accepted no
royalties for this whatsoever none
not one cent
i did it out of pure patriotic duty
and i stand by those words